the saddest most pathetic clip I've seen
from the world stage in a very long time
took place yesterday when Justin Trudeau
the rumored bastard child of Fidel
Castro but I listen that is a conspiracy
theory I don't buy I actually don't buy
it
he just behaves like Fidel Castro's son
but the prime minister of America's top
hat Justin Trudeau
had an impromptu meeting at the G20 with
Chinese president for Life Xi Jinping
the power dynamics were
pathetic
everything we discussed everything we
discussed has been leaked to the papers
that's not appropriate says she
that is not the way the conversation was
conducted says she there's poor Justin
Trudeau like a deer in the headlights
there was sincerity on your part Justin
he starts to walk away
[Music]
and Justin was total beta moves as well
you know we have a free exchange and
we're gonna she won't even look at him
let's create the condition let's create
the conditions first bye see ya just
walks away from him poor Trudeau
you can tell he's like shaking as he
walks away portrait he can't he's
wobbling he's so it feels so awkward
it's so pathetic big daddy she is
obviously the power player in this
Dynamic and poor little Justin Trudeau
is cowering and this is really sad for
us
because Canada is and always has been
America's Top Hat I I use that phrase
somewhat jokingly but Canada really is
just sort of an extension of America and
the broader kind of anglo-american
sphere of influence and we used to be
the top guys in the world stage it did
not used to be the case that the Chinese
could come up to the westerners and boss
us around and tell us what to do and
dress us down in public
that did not happen that does happen now
because we have lost leverage and Power
on the world stage we are in an era of
Western decline
and Chinese ascent and this didn't just
come about organically or accidentally
this was a policy just as we were
talking at the top of the show about
this strange situation we're in where
Americans aren't having children wow
it's so weird how did we get there oh
Whoopsie Daisy yes we need Mass
migration
no it didn't just happen Whoopsie Daisy
it happened intentionally because in
part of changes to our immigration laws
in the first place which depressed wages
and
and discourage people from having kids
but also all the laws on sex the
complete redefinition and abolition of
marriage
the abortion laws
the promotion of contraception
the
forcing of women into the workforce it's
always phrased as we're allowing women
into the workforce oh yes no women have
the opportunity to go make widgets for
Mr McGillicuddy down at the factory but
is that really how it works for most
women
I know a lot of women who would like to
stay home and raise their kids I know a
lot of women who would prefer that but
they can't do it because you can't raise
a family in America on one income
anymore they have to work
and then they have to pay a bunch of
money to some other woman to raise their
kids for them
it's
in in practice
our current labor laws
Force women into the workforce much more
than they give women the opportunity to
go work at the widget Factory okay and
that it didn't just happen accidentally
these are laws that we have passed to do
this sort of thing well it's the same
thing with national Decline and Chinese
Ascent Joe Biden was on the record I
think it was about 10 years ago he said
China's rising and that's a good thing
for everybody Rising title lifts All
Ships it's good that we're encouraging
China
to grow and rise and become very very
strong
and this was I don't mean to just blame
Biden and the Democrats Biden's been
around forever so he Bears some
responsibility for it he was a big
promoter of this but it was the
Republicans too
it was both parties that encouraged
China to enter the World Trade
Organization we went really soft in our
trade deals with China
we encouraged them to we let them steal
our IP we let them illegally devalue
their own currency we let them do all
sorts of things that gave them an
advantage over us and now we see the
consequences of that we and our little
vassals up there in Canada like Justin
Trudeau get dressed down very very sad
it is funny in that exchange I'm sort of
rooting for she you know
and and Justin Trudeau I actually kind
of get a kick out of she dressing him
down but it's sad it's sad for our
civilization and it shows our relative
status in the world right now head on
over to establishtitles.com Knowles
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of Lord or lady and
gain the respect you deserve all you
need is a one square foot plot of land
in Scotland okay I had this problem
where I thought I'm just not getting the
respect that is due to me okay people
when they come up to me they say hey
Michael
hey Mr note mister
I want to be referred to as a lard or a
lord okay there is this uh wonderful
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as Lords and Ladies well in
your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are a couple
packs because you don't want to let your
wife you know just be some strumpet
you're a Lord and then she's just some
chick on the street so you want her to
be a lady as well established titles
told me that the first 200 people to
purchase a title pack using my exclusive
link will receive a plot within walking
distance of mine depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or a lady
we can begin to build our own kingdom
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now and if you use
code Knowles at checkout you will get an
additional 10 off go to
establisheditles.com Knowles to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
now speaking of world leaders there is a
shocking new poll out this is from The
Economist and yougov it shows Ron
DeSantis
not just gaming on Trump not even just
tied with Trump he is way up on Donald
Trump the poll asks if you had to choose
who would you rather see as the
Republican nominee for president 2024
51 chose DeSantis 33 percent chose Trump
17 are not sure that means Ron DeSantis
right now in this poll is 18 points up
on Trump
polls generally mean nothing primary
polls this far out and National primary
polls also don't really mean very much
because the primaries are conducted in
States
and if DeSantis gets in he won't be the
only one to get in I bet there will be a
lot of other candidates who get in and
so you'll see a big splitting of the
vote and it could be the case that that
Donald Trump then just gets a plurality
and this is what happened in 2016. he
didn't have the majority of the vote in
these states but he had the plurality
and the other guys stayed in the race a
long time and Donald Trump got the
nomination all of that might happen
but this should worry Trump
that he is falling this far behind
this early on
I I assume this is why Trump declared
early
I think this is why Trump's speech was
relatively restrained as he wanted to
show that he can he can be Trump without
the downsides he can be what they're
billing to Santa says but this is
leading to a GOP Civil War whether we
want to admit it or not Ronda Santos was
just asked about it here's his answer
look I think we we just we just finished
this election okay people just need to
chill out a little bit on some of this
stuff I mean seriously we just ran an
election
we have this Georgia runoff coming which
is very important for Republicans to win
that Georgia runoff I mean I know around
the country Florida was kind of the the
biggest bright spot it was not so bright
in many other parts of the country it
was a it was a it was a substandard
performance given the Dynamics that are
at play so hopefully we'll be able to be
able to do that but I think what people
like me who've been given the
opportunity to continue is okay uh let's
do something with that and the reason
why we want historic Victory is at the
end of the day we LED we delivered and
we had your back when you needed us that
that is why we won big
DeSantis goes on we don't have the clip
he goes on to say and so we're going to
continue to deliver we are not going to
look back
I think that's very very significant so
he gives a good answer here he doesn't
talk about Trump specifically but this
is all about Trump he says look people
like me who have been given the
opportunity to continue right unlike
Trump who only got one term me I got
reelected so here's what we're going to
do and I'm not going to look back
Trump's speech was all looking back look
at what I did look at what I did look
we're not looking back we're looking
forward so he is tailoring all of his
answers here they're in a somewhat
veiled way
but nevertheless these are barbs back at
Trump trump started the fight DeSantis
is throwing these Jabs not openly yet
but folks we're two years out and it's
already getting this testy between Trump
and DeSantis
and what I urge people and I I have
urged my fellow conservative pundits
public figures politicians I've
suggested to people hey we have
primaries for a reason let this thing
play out you don't need to just dig your
heels in and be the most hardcore I'm
DeSantis or die or I'm Trump or die or
I'm I don't know Tim Scott or die I
don't know how many of those people
there are but you you know we're very
we're very early we we as a party have a
primary process for a reason it's okay
you don't need to pretend that Trump
wasn't the best conservative president
of your lifetime you know he was you
know he was you don't need to pretend
that you hate Trump you probably love
Trump he's a very lovable guy likewise
you don't need to pretend that DeSantis
hasn't done a good job in Florida he's
done a great job in Florida he's a good
candidate there's no question about that
it's okay guys it's all right people
don't like
uncertainty it gives them anxiety and
they don't like it and so people just
want to rush to a conclusion well life
is about cultivating patience and
resignation in large part these are
virtues okay and you've got you've got
to let things play out in their due time
I will be hosting a panel right now in
the member block
of women
of good-looking normal women from around
the country to explain to me the appeal
of ski Davidson the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]